foreign
I've told you guys how stupid I was
multiple times but I'm focusing on the
things where I almost killed other
people cool
[Music]
so uh me and my brother we'd like to go
into the woods a lot and one time we go
out there with a saw because we saw this
vine on this tree that we were going to
cut down and we're going to swing on and
so we get out there and we cut down this
fine
we unwrap it from the tree and we tug on
it a few times we're like yeah that's
that's sturdy yeah that could definitely
hold us up
and uh this other kid
was walking through the woods as well so
this kid came over
and what me and my brother saw was a
perfect test subject
for the Vine
and the problem with this Vine or what
made it so great was that it opened up
over this kind of Ravine and at the
bottom of this Ravine were just a bunch
of thorn bushes
so we talked this kid over here and
we're like hey check out this Vine that
we just cut oh did you swing on it
already and me and my brother went yeah
of course your turn and so uh this kid
uh he just gets a running start on he so
his way back swings as hard as he can
swings super far out and like at the
Apex of his swing
the vine snaps and he just plummets
right into the foreign
[Music]
and to us it looks like he just went
into like the jaws of like spinning
blades of death I'm sure that like
childhood brain made this much more
distorted and then he just like gets out
of the bushes and you see like Thorns
sticking out all over him he's got like
little Trails of blood running down
I'm gonna go home now
so me and my brother thought we were in
so much trouble that we decided to bury
the saw what the like legitimately
there's a saw buried by a tree in the
woods like by my childhood home if
anyone finds it you know what happened
there and you can't tell a soul
so that's a little mini Story the
bearing of the saw is a concerning
Instinct that's a very murdery instinct
I think the kid's alive who knows but
there's actually another there's another
simple thing it's a it's a much quicker
story so far
so when uh me and my brother were
slightly older we were staying over in
my mom's apartment and the apartment
complex has a lake outside it's middle
of winter so the lake is kind of Frozen
oh hell yeah so me and my brother were
like testing the edges and we step out a
little bit and it's holding our weight
the only problem is in the center we
definitely see that the center is not
Frozen
but over time as we're playing we get a
little closer and a little closer and
this other kid comes over and he's like
hey you guys playing out there and we're
like yeah yeah come on it's safe
and so he comes out and he's playing and
it's fine at first and then you know
where he asks us like if it's safe near
the hole in the center and we're like
yeah it's good it's good man
so the kid goes near the center and
he just falls right through right and
then he's down beneath the water but he
comes right back out me and my brother
do nothing to go near him and he comes
out and he's dripping water and then uh
he's like I'm gonna go home now like it
might have been the same kid from the
farm Bush I'd like to think this is the
same guy the funniest thing was like he
walks away and like this guy apparently
had been watching us from his balcony
this like old man was like Hey you
shouldn't play on the ice
my brother
oh okay
I'll start this off by saying I didn't
kill anybody if you want to check out
this full story and hear more click
right here on the video if you click
this you'll go to this story and hear so
many more we upload twice a week now and
also be sure to give love to the
animators their links are in the
description send them love more
animations through the link in the
description below and uh
I didn't kill anybody